[Music]
your favorite chicken thighs first of
all
we'll turn on the grill
the reason why we're using the thighs ie
the brown meat is so it doesn't go dry
season a nice
[Music]
salt pepper
olive oil
then turn them over please
come on get your hands in there good
don't worry about your nail polish
so there's no bones in there so the
chicken will cook really quickly
why do you do it skin side down skin
side down first that will stop the
chicken from going dry and it'll get it
really nice and crispy
good
see the way it's marked the skin now
yeah got all that really nice flavor in
there as well and we'll turn them every
two or three minutes how much do you
love chicken
lots lots i'm gonna serve that some
really nice chickpeas first we're gonna
make a little dressing okay
one nice teaspoon of mustard in please a
little bit of olive oil
a touch of salt
and pepper
give that a really good mix
and then
just squeeze lots
of lemon juice in there a little taste
it's nice
that is delicious
now look at that chicken now
follow that beautiful nice and crispy as
well
turn the gas down now and leave that
chicken to griddle right let's get the
chickpeas done shall we yep
so we've got peculiar peppers so these
are roasted
smoked spanish peppers a little taste
i would like you to chop up the
kettleberries
you take off the
the top i'm gonna slice them in half
like that wash your fingers
oh well okay
so these are small tequila peppers
yeah it's a bit sweeter there you go
with your fingers please watch your
fingers please tuck them in three finger
rule come on holly
you know the three finger rule i've been
telling you that since six months old
good girl you're fast aren't he yeah in
fact you're faster than jack don't tell
him we'll get him upset shut up at the
puppies then yes please thank you
good and then give it a little mix for
your fingers
please
love it run poles
out come on
out
get out every time there's food is
always there he smells it from a mile
away
the chicken's grilling it's inside down
why is it on
skin sides out because it keeps getting
moist
keeps it really nice and moist that's
right now
we'll start the watermelon salad
watermelon
feta
cucumber
pan nice and hot
you get the pecans okay and just sort of
break them up
i'm going to start slicing the
watermelon
you keep the seeds in yeah these are
fine so you just make these little boats
and go around like that
now with a toasted pecans give them a
little seasoning would you please with
pepper too um no just touch your salt
thank you roll them around and just
start to see them smoking see now turn
the gas off please
we're just to take half the cucumber and
give that a little peel for me please
nuts are nicely dry roasted
take them off
so from there i want you then to slice
around the seeds
that's the watery part okay we keep that
out
wash your fingers please
nice
am i still faster than jack you are
still very fast
a lot faster than jack now
cucumber on top of the metal we'll mix
it up in a minute i'm going to give that
a nice little light seasoning a touch of
salt and a little touch of pepper please
crush those little bits pecans in there
fine
nice
next greek feta cheese
this is kind of easy isn't it
jack
that fat and lump snoring you gotta get
him out of it hurry up mate take him out
fat lazy lump snoring his head off come
on out
so got that nice juicy melon the
cucumber and now the cheese we need
something to bring it to life oh taste
that's sumac okay that is very citrusy
we're just gonna season that
lightly now what i want you to do is
sprinkle the pecans in there
what's that
basil mint mint
minty
sorry you get confused with battle your
boyfriend
no daddy okay good keep it that way for
another 10 years
fresh mint over
and then
a little drizzle
of olive oil okay don't mix it yet i
know you're dying to get in there aren't
you
i'm just some fresh lemon juice
why'd you roll it it starts to release
all the juice let's now feel it
so it's less firm a little bit more
squashy
no
it's all that lemony is coming out now
what we need to do
is
what do you taste
everything yummy it's fresh isn't it
so that's the salad done
next a refreshingly light dessert of
lemon and basil granita
start by putting the juice of seven
lemons
and the zest of one into a small pan
with a sprinkling of caster sugar
stir over medium heat
until the sugar dissolves
dilute your granita mix with a little
water
[Music]
pour into a freezer-proof container stir
in a good handful of chopped fresh basil
and place covered in the freezer for
three hours
when the granita is frozen around the
edges lightly break up the mixture with
a fork
to the freezer and repeat twice until
the granita is frozen with a granular
texture
spoon into chilled serving glasses
garnish each with a sprig of basil
amazingly light and refreshing lemon and
basil granita
with our granita and feta salad done and
the griddle chicken beautifully charred
we can put the final touches to our main
course
i'll take the chicken
look how juicy that is see what i want
you to do now with a basil yeah is to
get big leaves i just want to tear them
in there
there you go
start lifting the chicken up please and
putting it in the chickpeas
oh that juicy amazing chicken
remember this little baby here
a vinaigrette
the heat of the chicken will infuse the
basil because the chicken's nice and
warm
melt the basil
and turn this salad into something
really delicious that smells so nice
doesn't it
see how we've glazed the chicken
[Music]
slide that onto our plate
how gorgeous is that
got that roasted pepper flavor
fresh basil
those wonderful chickpeas with a cake of
berries i think jack will like this one
you think jack would like this one yeah
yeah i'm megan until even really
interesting let's go
well done
[Music]
this is my ultimate light dinner
griddle chicken thighs with chickpeas
and a lemony dressing
feta and watermelon salad
and for a refreshingly zingy end to the
meal lemon and basil granita
first things first i'd like you to
season the stewing steak
a nice spoon of flour
mix yeah
good girl what's the flour going to do
dad the flour helps to brown the beef
a seasoned flour will also help to add
flavor and thicken the stew
i feel a bit like marshmallows
they do feel a little bit marshmallow
don't they look at the size of the
chunks of the beef
i'm going to cut my carrots literally
similar size that's right does that mean
they'll cook equally that's right
now these
are little pearl onions i'm going to put
them in hole as well
everything
has to stay the same
otherwise it could burn oh we've seen
burn garlic before
oh matilda
she promised you weren't going to
mention that
what was that
time
time and were they
baileys ladies good girl a tablespoon of
oil in
the beef goes in first okay
in
a really nice color got a beautiful
color
remember the carrots thyme in
good go
garlic
pearl onions in
good
give that a really good mix up
[Music]
easy to make daddy stews are very easy
to make providing at the beginning you
give it a little bit of love
now that's all beautifully browned
that bin that is beer and that's going
to deglaze the pan
adding beer or stout helps to tenderize
the beef and give it a hearty delicious
flavor
and that's the only way i want you to
taste beer
in a stew
yeah
i'm going to add in a couple of
teaspoons of tomato puree please
in fact three please
because it's so nice
and there's one final thing in there
cover this chewing steak with the beef
stock give that a little mix with daddy
please
wow that's really nice it's not even
cooked yet do you keep all these
vegetables in when you um serve it oh
yes is the garlic going to be burnt no
excuse me
right and we always put the lid with a
little bit just a little bit so it can
breathe that's right not make the stew
all watery into the oven at 150 please
tails for about two and a half hours and
now
you can focus on your homework
fun
time to knock up two delicious hearty
potato classics in one twice baked
bubble and sweet jacket potatoes
start by baking large potatoes in a
preheated oven at 180 degrees
shred one third of your savoy cabbage
and saute in butter and add a dash of
water until tender
[Music]
after about half an hour your potatoes
should be crisp on the outside and cook
through in the middle
slice them in half and scoop out the
soft potato center
then mash with a couple of knobs of
butter mix in the cabbage and season to
taste
spoon this mixture back into your potato
shells and into the oven for a further
10 minutes or until the tops are nice
and crispy and golden
two delicious hearty potato classics in
one twice baked bubbling squeak jacket
potatoes
[Music]
right homework done yep beef juice
chewing stewing let's get on with our
delicious hearty pet art i've been
looking forward to this
you and i chef i'm going to prep the
pears so if you peel
i'll top and tail
into quarters pears go soft in the oven
very very quickly so we're going to put
them on a tart you'll need to leave them
whole half or in quarter
what's that in there
ginger that's right a stem ginger so you
need stem ginger and fresh ginger
next add your stem ginger a little of
the stem ginger syrup good girl and some
brown sugar to your quartered pears
and then just grab some fresh ginger off
you go so it's a bit of a um different
one to grate this because it doesn't
really come through like the cheese no
i'm gonna make that a little bit zesty
now we've got some lemons some lemon
zest in there
right what we need to do now is give
that
a nice little mix
now this is a sweet pastry you can buy
this stuff where you make it it's so
easy to do
so give me your finger
that's my center point i want you to get
the pears going around
like that a really nice circle
it's difficult isn't it because the
pears keep on sliding all over the place
yeah
so egg wash the outside and i'm going to
show you a little trick
so you lift that up so see egg wash
acting like a bit of a glue that's right
crimple this with our finger
and the paste reforms this nice little
shelf
like a little money bag are you going to
do anything with the spare pairs oh yeah
you start building that up then you see
look at the fresh ginger
and those nice little bits of stem
ginger
let me go around like with your glue
we might glue just on top
tilly's last job is to give our tart a
good dusting of icing sugar so that
caramelizes it and colors the pears
beautifully it's a bit like snow isn't
it now that glaze is a pastry so the
pastry has this really nice shine on
there as well finally the lemon on top
and then put that there
180 and in she goes
can you smell the beef smells delish
wow it's even gone down a bit more
hasn't it look at that i want you to
just i was hoping you'd ask just have a
little taste
[Music]
how's that taste now
i'm not allowed anymore
all right
dumpling time flour in please i'm using
self-raising flour for a fluffy result
but if you like your dumplings hard use
plain flour next the dumpling essential
suet
that makes the dumplings nice and moist
thank you
followed by a generous dollop of grain
mustard
two fingers
start rolling the fingers round and i've
got a touch of warm water here
your fingers are now a nice little whisk
your fingers are getting tired all right
now put your hand in there now you
should bring
all that dough together
i'll show you the best way to get that
nice and clean sprinkle the flour on
your hands rub them together
all that will come off nice
that's a good way isn't it
now we've got this wonderful dumpling
mixture
how squidgy is that
a little flour on your hands okay
roll these lengthways
and then i want you to
fall in like that in your hand
off we go
smell that mustard in there
huh
come on i never trust you with something
like that
yes please
silly
gently
let's go in
at 12 o'clock
one o'clock
12 in the center
put that back into the oven for 20
minutes to cook the dumplings now if you
open the door for daddy i'm going to
take out that tart
oh it smells so nice doesn't it
our pet art has had 35 minutes in the
oven look at that baby
that looks good
would you like me to start dusting yes
please
nice and gently all the way around good
girl
little taps
the others are gonna love this it looks
a bit like a snowy cake doesn't it good
job
now very carefully carry that
to the table
how nice does that look
delicious okay i'll check on the
dumplings
now
look
they've sort of doubled in size
whoa definitely
a final sprinkle of chopped parsley and
our stew is ready for the table
i might have to have a quick taste
before we go
just to check i mean we do have to be
sure we have to be very sure
[Music]
that is an amazing hearty beef stew with
dumplings right the twice baked loaded
potatoes
and we are ready
this is my ultimate hearty dinner
a comforting rich beef stew with mustard
dumplings and twice baked bubbling
squeak jacket potatoes
and to make sure your sweet tooth is
completely satisfied a rich and zingy
pear and ginger galette